how should a screenwriter spend their
time let's say for ten hours that they
dedicate to their career how many of
those ten hours should be developing an
idea actually writing the screenplay
watching movies which again could go
into research networking reading etc I
think we've spent our life watching and
that we should continue to do so but
that's not really homework it's just
what we do and what we love and now we
don't have to feel guilty about it you
know great okay terrific so you're doing
that anyway as far as networking goes it
is the question of keeping your eyes
open shaking hands making friends
capitalizing on relationships that
that's also that can also happen at the
same time this is all sort of
multi-platform stuff that you're doing
anyway so when it comes to the real time
spent for writing right you know you
can't really count any of those things
as well I was writing because I was
watching TV and I was making a friend
you got right is that what Seth Godin he
calls the work do the work that scares
us it's always that that sounds sounds
right to me right what is the work that
you see scare most people that come in
to your classes that you know I think it
the work that scares people it depends
but often I see it in sort of the
rewrite process where you have spit out
that first draft where you have written
the scenes that you love and then
there's this you know a problem area
that you have to tackle and first of all
figuring out how to fix it that's that's
hard but even when you know how to fix
it sometimes it's not what you want to
do and it's but you have to that is the
place where it's hardest I think but
once you get past through past past that
through that I think that it's probably
the most rewarding because you really
did the hard work you know just focusing
back on joyce carol oates book the faith
of a writer she has a chapter on failure
I think she touches briefly that a lot
of artists are attracted to failure
hey do do you have an opinion on that I
don't know I'm not really good at you
know figuring out the psyche of artists
when you're in my class you know I'm
always like leave the drama on the page
you know I want to hear about it let's
get writing you know that's sort of how
how I work and I always feel like sort
of the writing pushes through the issues
or you can take those issues and give
them to a character this can be really
cathartic for you but as far as people
being attracted to failure maybe one
kind of writer is I don't know if all
writers are I think some people are just
attracted to storytelling
you